what's up everybody zacky here from geek
culture and today we have another epic
unboxing of the assassin's creed
valhalla collectors edition along with
two epic ubi collectibles which is the
avor the wolf kiss statue and the
assassin's creed valhalla hidden blade
so without further ado let's get to the
unboxing so here is the assassin's creed
valhalla collector's edition
very nice packaging all over
all got the celtic symbols
and of course the contents on the back
but
never mind that
let's just unbox it and see what we got
so the first thing we have
is the assassin's creed valhalla
ultimate edition which includes the full
game season pass and the ultimate pack
for ps4
yes
it also mentions that it is a ps5
upgrade available
so if you guys have a ps5
um you're in luck yeah
and underneath that is the assassin's
creed valhalla pre-order bonus
it's called the way of the berserker and
we're not going to show the code
and below that you also have the limited
edition steelbook case
which has the assassin's creed
[Music]
symbol and of course
a bird i'm not sure what bird it is
but
yes very nice color
and that's what it looks like inside
yeah
so we also have a what seems to be a
pouch so let's open this up
and this is the
[Music]
and this is the assassin's creed
valhalla
pouch
hidden in that pouch
is
a
totem of viking totem
let's see if we can get focused there we
go
[Music]
very nice very cool
in another box
let's see what's inside
in the first tier
you have
a
in the first year you have the selected
game soundtrack
of assassin's creed valhalla
it's uh
comes in a very nice disc
very cool
and
and
underneath that is the statue
and before we go on to the statue this
is the
certificate of authenticity
with us having the
five
the 59th thousand
with us being the fifty nine thousand
nine hundred and ninety third
uh listen to own the collector's edition
it's pretty nice pretty nice artwork as
well
yeah and there is an envelope so let's
check it and see what
was that about
so here is the envelope
and
what it seems
we can get it out
there's some
some lovely postcards of the concept art
of assassin's creed valhalla
and they are in the corners right here
you can see
and in the corners
they're signed by the concept artists
yeah the signatures right here so that's
very interesting very cool
thanks guys awesome work
so here we have the 30 centimeter female
evil
statue
figurine which ever call it and it comes
with
um
very nice x
as a weapon
yeah pretty cool
[Music]
as well as
um the raven
is it a raven let us know down in the
comments whether we are right about this
particular bird i believe it's a raven
and just to give you a little bit more
of a close-up of the details here
[Music]
so there's evil
there's a cool haircut by the way
nice shield
it's very nice
pretty amazing how they did the the
cloth
this is a pvc
but it feels very sturdy
and solid
so
yeah
interesting
this is so
the details on the boat
you can see like there's some pores you
can see that there's some pores like
textures here and
the paints and how the the wood is done
it's very nice details
look at the
the bust
so is it a dragon is it a horse
a sea serpent
let us know in the comments below what
this is
yeah down to the level of detail
of the boots and strips
very nice
it's pretty solid one actually
and even the details
on her armor
and
what she's wearing from the sash and
everything
yeah
and the detail on the hidden blade
if you can see that
let's see yeah right here
pretty solid stuff
here's some details of a face
very nice
you can see on top here
there's a hole and that's where the
raven is perched on
so let's just put that
there we go
cool
[Music]
very nice
and let's
let her old
x
all right so we've got the female evil
and now we've got the male evo
it's called the evil wolf kissed
and
it's also a playable character
in assassin's creed valhalla
there's just some of the designs in the
box
this is a ub collectible
and yeah you can get it at the ub store
all right so
a little bit more on what it looks like
and let's unbox it
so let's get to this unboxing
let's put this box away
very nice
and here we have
an illegal let's
tear it apart
here we have
the male
evil
standing on a chest of gold silver
very very nice details on the uh
on the chest
and even the ground
very nice detailing
on the leather
the shoes the bootstraps
and the moldings
excellent actually very impeccable i
love the flow of the material
it just looks so good man okay sash just
flowing
and
his uh
helmet over there very nice
moving on he too has a hidden blade with
a nice jade
gem of salts
all right moving on to his head
and his chest
very nice detailing like the fur
and stuff
still don't do haircuts
really want a haircut like that man
or if i can even grow a beard like that
it'll be epic
yeah
very cool to give this a nice spin
very nice
um
very nice what do you call it
posture
is that what it called posture
yeah i'm just going to say posture
positioning i guess i don't know
and these are
the
two side by side let me bring it closer
so you can see
the differences
between the both of them looks very nice
actually wow
kind of kind of blends in actually if
you have two of them side by side
let me adjust the camera here
yeah
that's what they look like back to back
[Music]
back so
of course the the female evil would
kind of be a little bit on the bigger in
terms of
the size of
it because she has nice the whole boat
thing going on
nevertheless both of these are very very
detailed figurines
don't you think so let us know in the
comments
would you prefer to have the
male evil or the female evil and how do
you find it if you really ordered it
totally forgot about this as well
this is the male evils x
very different
from the female evil let me take this
out
come on
so on my right is the female evil and
the last side is the middle evil female
is a little bit shorter
[Music]
darker
and bigger voice
more shiny more chrome
more i won't say it's hefty but you know
kind of looks heavy and stuff but wow
look at the details on this
it's crazy
right
so let's put
male
evols x
right took a little bit of finicking but
this is his axe
and
for female evil
same thing right here
wow
that's damn bloody cool
look at that
oh
damn
they just look so great
standing together
oh yes speaking about that we still got
a hidden blade so
let's unbox
this let's move this behind
there we have the assassin's creed
valhalla hidden blade ub
collectible
here's your small designs here
very simple
content and description
there's a locking mechanism a blade
release system in a spring-loaded
retractable blade
so
let's unbox this
all right check this out folks i'll take
this off the plastic
nice uh kind of a soft
i'm guessing
it's probably not actual leather but it
does have the texture
of leather
i'm giving this a spin
it's the details
nice green jump here
a little bit of
black etching
uh give it some depth
yeah
very nice
nice textures as well all the way down
here
and uh that's what the vambraces look
like
it's not really leather
um
it's got like i know latex sometimes has
a particular latex fuel
and a little bit of full
fur over here
and
yeah it's with velcro so
i'm guessing
you gotta unbuckle it first
all this
so a lot of buckles
um
yeah
interesting texture
and they really try their best to make
it look like leather though so
kudos to them
and this is essentially velcro
so all you need to do is put your arm in
[Music]
velcro right back
this is so hard oh but here's an
interesting detail
within the latex you can also see the
assassin's creed logo
assassin's creed valhalla will be
collectible with possibly the trademarks
in this real number yeah
and the vocal doesn't really stick
[Music]
oh it's gonna take a while okay
[Music]
oh the vikings did it
[Music]
okay
and then strap over
all right so here we have
the
sentence created blade
took a while to wear it
it's not exactly
the most fitting
you know because it's
latex not really free form
no
let me do this properly
yeah
um
quite hefty
it does have a bit of give you know it
gets loose
um but
very
very interesting
uh thing can definitely
cosplay with it
very nice details
very cool
[Music]
um yeah does take a while to
get suited on
as you can see it's not really
the easiest to wear
so how do we um
i'm guessing press the button here and
the heater will come out so
huh
still trying to figure out
why is it not popping out
okay so there is a switch
if i can contort my hand
maybe you see it here right so
it's a little
switch here which is the locking
mechanism
i'm not sure you can see it let me find
yeah there you see it
right there
so you gotta
move that button
into here click
and then three
two one
cool
let's try that again so the
blade itself is not auto
retractable so you gotta like push it
and um you have to worry the tip is
soft super flimsy
um but yeah again
um
once you have disengaged the lock you're
free to
shoot so very cool
surprising yeah i was just sure i always
assumed that the blade was going to be a
lot longer but
interesting
should be the ring finger wasn't it
yep super
freaking but nonetheless
it's not a smooth
retractable thing as well but you can
definitely hear the
spring
and yeah just one more time for you guys
go go gadget
oh
oh
okay three two one google gadget
there we go
schwing
i don't know should do this i guess oh
yeah how does it work for people to stab
it's a weird concept usually it should
be this way wasn't it
but yeah there you have it
so there you have it my fellow geeks
this is the quick unboxing of the
assassin's creed valhalla collector's
edition along with its lovely female
evil
figurine as well as two ub collectibles
which is the male evil the wolf kiss and
the assassin's creed valhalla hidden
blade well that's it for the video we
hope you guys enjoyed and if you do
do give us a thumbs up do let us know
down in the comments which is your
favorite part of the collection
and if you haven't already do consider
subscribing and smash the notification
bell icon so you can stay updated to our
latest unboxings geeky reviews and
tidbits
until then this is zaki
wahoo
[Music]
you